à l'étranger,
nous avions une costumière Deborah Scott
, lauréate d'un Academy Award avec qui j'avais travaillé
depuis Titanic, elle devait en quelque sorte avoir un
pied dans les deux mondes parce qu'elle devait
concevoir tous les costumes pour la RDA mais
elle devait aussi avoir toute l'autre
moitié  de son cerveau pour concevoir tous les
costumes et les bijoux et les conceptions de
cheveux et la décoration des cheveux et tout
pour ne pas être la conception de costumes est l'une des
parties les plus importantes de l'expression d'un
personnage comment une personne s'habille ce que
ses vêtements signifient dans un clan des gens
qui jouent différemment  fonctions le
chef le pêcheur un enfant que tous
ces gens ont une place différente dans
le clan
nous avons fait des recherches sur les peuples autochtones
littéralement dans le monde entier l'environnement dans
lequel vivent les clans est extrêmement
important pour ce qu'ils portent
donc les américains sont des gens de la forêt ils
utilisent des choses du pandorien  forêt l'
humanité est beaucoup plus adaptée à l'eau
vous n'êtes pas de bons plongeurs peut-être bons pour se
balancer à travers les arbres mais l'une des
principales raisons pour lesquelles  t nous avons fait les
vêtements à la fin est le mouvement
du vêtement
ne peut pas être compris sans avoir la
pièce entière, donc si quelque chose est lourd ou
plumeux ou léger ou filandreux ou frangé
la façon dont ces choses se déplacent dans l'air
debout dans une brise sous l'eau à coup sûr
qui  est une énorme partie du film, vous devez
vraiment avoir l'échantillon pour voir
ce qui lui arrive.
des films seront réalisés
chaque tissu et chaque pièce tissée ou
chaque tresse et plume, ils ont tous
leur propre vie, ils bougent tous à
leur manière et ce n'est pas quelque chose que
vous pouvez obtenir en regardant simplement une œuvre
d'art et en la traduisant en un
écran nous travaillons avec de l'eau numérique sur une
base constante même la plus petite chose
comme un collier va pour le balayage où
il peut réellement le cartographier ils lisent la
texture ils lisent la couleur et ensuite
ils utilisent tout o  f cette information dans un
monde virtuel,
cette capacité que la réalité que nous parvenons
à apporter au film va à cent
pour cent la rendre plus réelle pour
tout le monde
[Musique]